you
[Music]
wait so thanks for coming to this talk
I'm gob or I work at our studio I'm a
software engineer and I will show you
today an R package that is called
actually not package man there is a name
change here but it's called just package
or PKG which is you know interesting if
you talk about the package package so i
would just probably call it PKG that
maybe sounds better so so PKG is a is a
package for package installation and i
will you know tell you briefly why we
are writing this package and what are
the goals that we want to have we
achieve and what features the package
has you know to achieve these goals and
a little bit about you know project
based workflows which is kind of the
long-term goals that we want to want to
have and about ongoing work ok
so goal number one so there is already a
way to install packages in alright in
base are there's a function you can use
you know to install packages and it
works actually pretty well it installs
packages from crayon or any kind of
crying like repository right and then
there are the tools some of them
developed at our studio like the dev
tools package and the remotes package to
install packages from from other sources
so there are a lot of tools already you
know that exists basically to install
packages so why are we writing a you
know another one so basically to
summarize it very you know simply we
want to have cheap and reliable package
installation and i will tell you you
know what I mean by cheap and reliable
so cheap is easy so it should be you
know minimal effort to install the right
packages for your projects in the light
rivalry using some simple you know short
function call and it should also be fast
you know this is actually very important
because if it's fast then it is ok to do
it you know kind of frequently and and
that in turn is important because the
kind of workflows we are shifting
towards to require you
more frequent package installation but
if you know this is you know hard and
slow then people will just not do it so
we would just not you know get those
workflows so reliable means these are
not very surprising things right so it
should leave the packages in a working
state that doesn't actually always
happen you know if it the existing tools
so we're trying to make you know more
make an effort that this this happens
and your your package is installed in a
working state and it's not in a broken
state because of some error happens you
know halfway to do the installation we
want to leave the project in a working
States you know and all the dependencies
are properly satisfied in your library
for your project we want to put all the
dependencies of a project in a single
library because this will help us with
with the verb floss we want to you know
tend towards to related to this if you
have multiple projects you know the the
dependencies and the packages you know
that you need for these multiple
projects they shouldn't they should not
interfere you know if you have if you
have a project that needs a certain
version of deep layer you know and then
you have another project that needs a
different version you know of the
applier because you just started that
project you know one year later and then
the deep layer of syntax may be changed
a little bit or or the semantics changed
a little bit then you know you should be
able to work with this you know two
projects without having any kind of
interview interference and of course so
package PKG is in our package itself so
it has its own dependencies and those
should not interfere obviously with your
regular you know project dependencies
either so how to make it fast
we did we did a lot of effort you know
to make PKG fast the first one is is to
make all the HTTP requests you know
concurrent so if you are installing
korean packages only then this is kind
of you know simple to achieve if you
have packages from other sources like
like packages from github or package
from from your own repositories you know
then it's it's a little bit harder
you know if typically if you're
installing a package from github you
have to make several requests to the
github API and then you know that
package that you're installing from
github might depend on other packages on
github and that means you need to make
even more requests to the github API so
if you don't do it if you don't do this
concurrently it will be just very slow
it's very simple the package builds and
the installations are also concurrent
you know some of the base tools based
are tools can do this too but obviously
we wanted to have it too
pkg is quite lazy so by default it
doesn't actually download or do anything
if it doesn't you know have to so if you
don't you know explicitly tell it to
that you want to update you know to some
newest version or a newer version then
you will not update you know if the
current version is good enough for your
project and it will not do anything it
will not update just for the sake of
updating and probably the most important
you know two features for speed is is
the cache the cached metadata and the
cached package for us so with the
current tools probably all of them
you know package to tools managing
packages and package installation you
know if you if you want to you know if
you install a package you know you need
to make a download if you can need to
download the package file if you do the
same thing five minutes later you'll
probably download it again which is not
how you know an ideal package manager
should work there should be some cache
and that makes it really really fast so
there are some safety features because
we want you know have a reliable way to
install packages the first fun seems
like a joke right so it's but it's
actually not so some of the tools
actually they don't fail if some error
happens and it would just you know they
would just leave you in a broken state
between a broken installation so it it's
nice to fail if there's an error you
know so if you can't restore something
you you should fail I mentioned this
already all the dependencies go in the
same library what pack what pkg does is
it it solves the dependency structure of
your installation and if there is a
problem with that it
towards it up front so it doesn't
actually start you know installing
packages until it knows that okay this
will this will be okay you will get a
consistent state of the library and it
reports all the conflicts up front and
then you can you know see what you can
do about those conflicts all the
dependencies of pkg itself there in the
private library so they don't you know
interfere with with your other normal
you know packages package dependencies
and this works you know this happens
seamlessly so you'd only really need to
you know worry about this pkg just push
them there and just uses them it also
uses a sub process to perform the
installation because in our and the
package system you know it's often a
problem if you want to install a package
that is loaded in a session okay so
usually when you when when you you know
your package installation fails then you
know the the older are users will tell
you to to you know quit all the our
sessions that you have and then start
with an empty session to install because
of because of this problem so to work
around this you know pkj uses a sub
process so its own dependencies are only
loaded in the sub process and they are
loaded from the private library so you
don't have this interference there yeah
and you also try to do you notice
attacks if you have a package loaded
from the library that you you don't want
to overwrite you want to install - just
just - you know detect these possible
problems okay so it has some convenience
features misterpost gran bios it
packages out of the box
github packages really easily so there
is something called the remotes filled
in the description file if you haven't
seen this before that allows you to
depend on non-standard packages you know
in your in your own package and make the
installation just work you know seem
seamlessly so you can put as an example
at the bottom so you can put this entry
in your description file and the first
actually both both lines both of those
dependencies refer to github so it's
just you know username slash repository
and then the second example it has a has
an ad dev that's a
John github it just means that you know
for this project or for this package you
need to install you know the glue
package from github and you actually
want to have the death branch so we
support all this this is not really new
you know that the F dos package has
supported this for a while and the
remotes package as well
it supports local package files and
package tree so you can install this
tree from you know files on your own
disk it's a nice convenient feature that
it will show you the download sizes you
know before you you actually do the
installation and also in the progress
bar so if you have like a big
installation and your internet is you
know not the best you will see you know
how long it will take to install that so
I will just show you a little demo you
know how this works
in in practice so that's just a very
basic our session that I have here is
this big enough for should I make it
bigger this should be good right okay so
so the main function that you use is
called package install and then you know
obviously cran and and bios bioconductor
packages or just forex seamlessly I will
give a separate library here not to you
know mess up my own libraries so I will
just install they were just installed
there so if you do this you know then
pkj will solve your installation you
will find all your dependencies and this
looks like this is the current package
you know crannies in a consistent state
almost always so the installation is
possible and you also tell you that it
will install you know these eighteen
packages and it will download them from
from train
I just cleared my cache so that's why
they are not they are not cached so if I
want to continue I just say yes and then
it will internet is really fast here so
if I download them very very quickly and
I will you know install them really
quickly so this is nothing surprising
right if you obviously if I run this
again you know then it would take a look
at the installed packages you know and
then see that actually it sees that
actually there's nothing to do so it it
does nothing right now the more
interesting case is that you know when
you when you install when you download
this package files it also adds
the package files to the cache so if I
were to completely remove this library
like this and I do this again and in a
more realistic situation you know what
what happens is that you just give your
project to somebody else to your
colleague and your project you know
dependencies are described in your in
your description file and your colleague
there you know install all the
dependencies for you for your project
now if your colleague has all these
packages in the cache like we do now so
it tells you that all eighteen packages
are cached so if these are commonly used
packages you know you don't actually
need to download them you know it it
will even if the internet was slow
though it is not slow here you know if
this is really fast because everything
is coming from the cache okay so github
packages work really easily bioconductor
packages as well you don't you don't
need to do anything you know special for
a bioconductor package this is a
bioconductor package it was just
automatically included the only glitch
with the bioconductor packages that we
don't know their size is upfront so it
will tell you you know that it will
download 16 packages from cran roughly
20 megabytes and and you know 12 more
packages that but the size of those is
known and it will obviously add all
these to the cache so if you do it again
you know the next time you don't need to
download them so four packages from
github say I can install pkg itself
maybe that's a good example
and it also tell you that you know there
is one package with unknown size and
that's the early / EKG package because
that's coming from github and we don't
know the sizes of those packages
actually and there are a bunch of
packages in this library that already
there so you don't actually even need to
install them yeah it needs to build PKG
because that's not a built package
it's just a repository so that's that's
how works the simple parts at least when
you go back to that yeah so I showed you
github packages and the other thing I
want to show you what happens if you
have a conflict
so I artificially created a conflict
here in this branch the conflict branch
so in this branch the PKG package
depends on a package version of some
other package that is not available so
if you try to do that you know this you
know PKG tries to solve the dependency
tree so this will come up immediately it
will tell you that it can't you know it
can't install package cache and then you
can look you know into your into your
dependencies and see why you know that
is the case another one another conflict
that i that i artificially created is is
the config branch of this package and if
i try to install this together with the
CLI package but not the master branch
let's say this branch and what happens
is the PKG package this branch of the
PKG cache package you know depends on
one version of of CLI so that's but you
can see there cannot install dependency
or the CLI master he wants the master
you know branch and but I also you know
upfront said that I wanted to install
this other branch and and you know our
libraries are just such that you can't
install two different versions of the
same package in the same library so this
is a conflict this is not you know
something that we can definitely do so
bkg tells you front ok so
so the main goal actually or the order
you know a longer term goal and the
reason why we want to make you know
package installation cheap and reliable
is that we want to have safe and
convenient workflows and this would be
workflows to though there are centered
on projects so I will show you one
workflow that is already possible with
the pkg package there is some more work
to be done to make this super convenient
but this if you organize you know your
project or your package this way it's
already works and it's relatively
actually easy to do it so so you would
have a new project or package you know
some files and directories that you can
sorry that you can see here so the our
directory is the usual you know place
for your code if if this is a package
you know this structure is not really
surprising the package usually has a
harder Ector it has a description file
right if it's a project you don't
necessarily need to create these but you
can obviously and if you do then PKG
will help you you know with the
installation and the separation of your
project libraries and so on so the
description file will be used to you
know describe the dependencies we need
to create an art profile dot our profile
file here which will set up you know to
your project library and it's very
simple so there's a short example in the
bottom basically it will source the main
our profile you know it will create your
directory for your library which will be
the hard - packages directory and then
it it makes sure that it is added to
your library path so that's the bottom
line and then in your description file
you can sort you can describe your
dependencies to use your way you know
either you can just use it depends or
imports field if this is a package but
potentially with versions and you can
also use the remotes field if you want
you know a package from a non you know
canonical source and then to do the
installation you know after you have
this set up you can use you know one of
those comments in the in the bottom so I
guess the most common one would be local
installed apps or local installed app
tab so they were installed you know all
your dependencies into the are -
packages you know library which which is
already set up in your profile
okay so so that was so this is a
relatively simple project based you know
workflow it's not super convenient
because it's not fully automated right
so you need to actually you know add say
the remote fields and so on so there's
some person work that you need to do you
know to to make this work you need to
create this art profile file
you know manually and so on so some of
the ongoing work is just to make this
better you know have have better tools
to you know to declare the dependencies
of a project say snapshot those
dependencies you know to know their
exact version so that when you deploy
your project you know you can recreate
those exact versions so that's so this
thing doesn't doesn't exist yet in pkg
and we are working on that and whether
you'll be in pkg package or not it's not
you know we don't know that yet but it
is definitely something that we want to
have would be nice to have you know
better failure diagnosed Diagnostics so
we working on that too you know so that
if if an installation fails then you
will tell you that it failed because you
don't have some library on the system
you know present and I've mentioned the
snapshotting already it's possible to
make it even faster and we will add
remote types so I will just leave you
with with this so this is the there are
links in the bottom the package is not
on cran yet but it should be on cran you
know anytime basically it's in the queue
so it can get there anytime until it
gets there you know an easy way to
install it is to excuse this install
github new service from github and you
can take a look at it at the repository
as well and that's all I have
[Applause]
thank you very much governor for that
introduction we may have time for one
very quick question on the other fronts
at Davis I just catch the microphone
there you go the most annoying part of
installing our packages is when you have
to come you have to build packages to
have compiled code like C++ from source
and so dudes are planning to add more
supports your package for to manage to
our dart make VARs file and like the
system path and so on
thank you thank you so yes we definitely
want to help with that so on one thing
is that you know if you manage to
install from source then we we had then
we had to packaging to the cache so you
don't need to do it again that's one
thing and the other thing is that we we
want to you know look at the system
requirements of your package to try to
figure out why you couldn't install it
and then give you some you know helpful
message you know what you know software
or libraries you need to install in your
system you know to look at the
installation done
[Music]